oh you may have heard that Nashville is
getting his second life because ABC
cancelled it your call but CMT is
bringing it back for you perfect place
for the show e t--'s TV editor Leeanne
Aguilera was with the show star Connie
Britton the day she heard the good news
and Connie knew exactly who to thank
Connie I got to congratulate you
Nationals coming back that was an
example of fans being really
enthusiastic and we really owe that all
to the fans their chance we could see
more Arena of course it's not the first
time passionate fans have saved one of
Connie shows they did the same for
Friday Night Lights you don't fight for
this I think we're gonna regret it now
ten years since the premiere 21 cast
members reunited at the 80 X Television
Festival in awesome when it was canceled
there was a huge outcry about that it
really felt to the audience like they
were right there with us I think it
really pulled at people's hearts to
celebrate they did a little tailgating
on the real Panthers field the memories
just that flood your mind when you come
and see this feel all over again we rode
a bus here to get to the actual field
which is what we would do when we were
filming like as the cast we would get on
a bus and drive to set so it was very
nostalgic I met some of my dearest
friends in the world on this show
because we were in the middle of nowhere
on this show like it was like a Lost
Island we all became such like dear
friends but while the cast is still
close they say fans shouldn't expect a
reboot we feel like we kind of caught
lightning in a bottle and I think it's
darn near impossible to do it again I
really think the show ended on that on a
good note and I think that maybe I let
it go like this like the stairs behind
us those are our bleachers look at them
they have trees growing on them nobody
is taking care of this place who's in
charge here love love love that show